180000 personnes ont défilé dans toute
la France une marche qui a été au cœur
des débats politiques he puisque la
présence du rassemblement national a
fait énormément réagir c'est pour ça
comme je vous l'ai dit il y avait trois
personnes à voir ce soir c'était où
Jean-Luc Mélenchon on était pas chaud
Emmanuel Macron a une prochaine fois et
Jordan Bardella petite compile des
rassemblements en France et Jordan
Bardella sera avec nous il sera face à
lactu on viendra avec lui sur toute
l'actualité et bien entendu on lui
posera la question voilà qui a beaucoup
tourné ces derniers temps regardez c'est
parti
allez plus fort non
l à
[Musique]
bon merci là d'être avec
nous président du Rassemblement national
euh on va revoir un des images bien
entendu de de de cette de cette marche
vous étiez très content de cette marche
euh content en tout cas c'est rassurant
d'avoir vu du monde dans les rues de
Paris ouais c'est rassurant parce que je
pense que les Français sont lucides sur
cette recrudaescence de l'antisémitisme
qui a touché tout le pays depuis le 7
octobre et sur la nécessité de se
rassembler euh
donc satisfait de la mobilisation Verant
qui dit que vous n'aviez pas votre place
à cette cette marche bah que monsieur
verérant n'est pas un homme d'État voilà
c'est un petit politicien qui fait de la
politique politicienne sur le dos d'une
cause qui devrait nous rassembler et en
faisant ça monsieur verérant qui est
ministre il ront l'unité nationale en
fait parce que normalement quand on a
une cause comme ça tous ceux qui sont
élus citoyens qui sont sensibles à ce
que vivent aujourd'hui les Français de
confession juive qui ne se sentent plus
en sécurité en France et qui s'y sentent
encore moins en sécurité depuis le 7
octobre devrai pourtant sera rassemblé
donc monsieur verrant divise les
Français et je trouve que il devrait
avoir un peu plus de hauteur et être un
peu plus responsable surtout quand on
est ministre on est plus militant
politique voilà on est ministre de tous
les Français euh vous avez vu vous avez
vous avez été bien accueilli à la
manifestation on a été très bien
accueilli va voir les images regardez
bon là j'ai
[Applaudissements]
l'air
[Musique]
alors ça c'est vous étiez content alors
de l'accueil en fait je pense que cette
manifestation cette marche é un moment
de vérité c'est que les quelques élus de
la nupes qui sont venus ont été hués
mais Hu conspué et nous qui apparaissons
aujourd'hui je crois alors vous aussi
aussi vous aussi par jeis vous raconter
j'étais sur place il y a un groupe de
militants d'une
organisation de 25 types en arrivant
lancé quelques slogans pour protester
contre votre venue voilà bon on est
passé devant ça a duré 10 secondes on
les a purevu de la manif et ensuite
pendant 2h et demi j'ai marché pendant
2h3 avec avec Marine et l'ensemble de
nos députés on a été très bien accueilli
et et et je pense que c'est un moment de
vérité parce que la nuupes queu ça
correspond aux positions qu'ils ont
prises et et nous ça correspond au fait
qu'on est devenu je crois aujourd'hui le
meilleur bouclier pour protéger les
Français de confession juivees de cet
antisémitisme 2.0 qui prend sa racine et
sa sour dans dans l'islamisme en fait
depuis 15 ans et ça fait 15 ans qu'on le
dénonce alors c'est c'est nouveau ça
alur non bah c'est c'est nouveau que les
gens se rendent compte mais vous soyez
le bouclier non je je ne crois pas ça
fait on l'aurait jamais imaginé il y a
quelques années
ça ça fait 15 ans en tout cas que non
Marine Le Pen excusez-moii vous
retrouvez des déclarations de Marine Le
Pen en 2011 avant les attentats de
Mohamed Mera qui dit la menace pour les
Français de confession juifes c'est
l'islamist moi j'ai grandi en sc saint
pourquoi il y a plus de Français de
confession Ju en sa saint pourquoi
est-ce que les Français de confession
juives quittent les écoles les rues les
immeubles les quartiers de la SA saintis
pourquoi est-ce que aujourd'hui il y a
des Français de confession juives qui
sont contraints de retirer les musas
pour les mettre à l'intérieur pourquoi
est-ce qu'il y a des Français de
confession juives qui retirent les noms
des boîes au lre vous leur posez la
question et ils vous diront qui les
effraie et qui leur fait peur et ceux
qui les fait peur ce sont des gens
aujourd'hui qui sur le sol de la
République française ne se considèrent
pas comme français et et se font les
relais de l'idéologie du Hamas donc oui
qu'est-ce qui se passe Val non mais
simplement moi je ça me fait sourire
tant mieux he si vous êtes en train de
faire votre grande mu c'est formidable
moi je l'avais pas vu la grande muie je
la découvre là tout d'un coup sur le sur
beaucoup de gens qui l'ont vu manifest
oui manifestement grand tuas le grand m
à côté mais voilà moi je je je n'oublie
pas alors effectivement vous n'êtes plus
le parti de Jean-Marie Le Pen vous êtes
le parti de Marine Le Pen mais moi j'ai
du mal par à oublier j'ai du mal à
oublier le détail de l'histoire j'ai du
mal à oublier du Rafour crématoire j'ai
du mal à oublier non mais et même et
même maintenant même maintenant
pardonnez-moi mais vous avez encore des
vous avez encore si j'ose dire du ménage
à faire dans vos rangs parce que il y a
encore un député RN dansok dont on dit
que il est le patron d'un d'une
librairie qui est connu pour des des
ouvrages négationistes du tout c'est
fa on va revenir làdus en fait ce qui
est juste intéressant en fait non mais
ce qui est intéressant moi j'assume
j'assume on a rompui pour cette marche
hier pardonnez-moi parce que moi je l'ai
faite je suis des confessions juive et
je me sens avant tout française impor
non mais vous avez raison vous vous
sentez menacé par qui en France par par
moi ou par des des gens qui se font les
relais deidologieintéressait moi hier
qui m'intéressait moi hier dans cette
manifestation c'était que c'était que
cette manifestation c'était une
manifestation qui Ava qui a été que vous
que tout le monde tout le monde
j'entends bien à l'extrême droite à
l'extrêmeuch a essayé de récupérer et à
laquelle et à laquelle les non mais
c'est c'est pas chiant à laquelle les
Français ont dit on ne veut pas qu'elle
soit récupérée
justement on va pas faire he sur la
marche moi j'ai rien récupéré du tout il
y a la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale le président du du Sénat qui
appelle tous les Français d'où qu'ils
viennent quel que soit leur sensibilité
politique y compris les mouvements
politiques à venir marcher pour dire aux
Français de confession juive vous n'êtes
pas seul vous n'êtes plus seul vous
devriez vous réjouir de voir que tous
les mouvements politiques à l'exception
de certains puis que Monsieur Mélenchon
d'ailleurs c'est voté dans dans la
dignité a dit en gros ceux qui vont
manifester hier senent de guerre
d'Israël ce sont les mots de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon mais maintenant je vous mets
très à l'aise moi j'ai rejoint le le mon
mouvement politique en 2012 c'était
Marine Le Pen voilà est-ce que je
leurais fait autant de Jean-Marie Le Pen
probablement pas il y a des millions de
gens aujourd'hui qui votent pour le
rassemblement national qui ne sont pas
des fachot qui ne sont pas des gens
d'extrême droite on représente 42 % des
voix lors l'élection présidentielle et
j'ai aucune honte à dire que Jean-Marie
Le Pen il a été condamné pour
antisémitisme mais ce que je trouve
injuste c'est que cette archéologie en
fait on l'a fait pour nous c'est que en
fait là depuis une semaine on nous parle
de Jean-Marie Le Pen qui a 95 ans qui
est retiré de la vie politique pour des
propos dont certains pour le point de
détail pour lequel il a été condamné en
justice ont 35 ans et on vient me
demander à moi alors que il y a des
Français de confessions juifes qui ont
peur il y a des porum qui on en Israël
de me justifier sur des propos de
Jean-Marie Le Pen qui a 95 ans et qui
s'est retiré de la vie politique donc
j'ai aucune honte à dire qu'on a tourné
la page de notre passé mais à ce
moment-là il faut le faire pour tout le
monde il faut le faire pour tous les
mouvements politiques vous savez les les
socialistes ils ont porté en 80 à la
présidence de la République Monsieur
mitteran qui avait reçu des
ch la plus haute réeich etétait desistes
une chambrealiste qui avé lesinir
maréchal Pétin donc l'histoire elle est
complexe on peut la faire pour tout le
monde mais en tout cas excusez-moi quand
vous voz Serge clarfeld qui pour le coup
a consacré sa vie à traquer les nazis
qui a consacré sa vie à la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme qui est un peu plus
sérieux pardon sur le sujet que Monsieur
verrant venir dire le rassemblement
national à sa place PhIP a qui dit vous
avz votre place aujourd'hui bah on voit
je Édouard Philippe c'est pas ma maison
politique mais on voit quand on compare
les propos entre Olivier verrand et
Édouard Philippe on voit la différence
entre un petit monsieur et un homme
d'État alors il y a pas mal de stars
aussi qui ont marché dans le Corte juste
mettez juste lilus non mais lilus lus
alors il y a qui alors il y a Carla
Bruni Karine Le Marchand Valérie Arthur
moi je devais je vous le dis je devais y
aller avec je devis y aller avec
jean-jaces Goldman à la base il m'a
appelé dans l'après-midi il m'a dit
finidalement je marche seul
voilà c'était pour un peu pour détendre
l'atmosphère allez on va revenir sur
l'actualité
Emmanuel Macron absent de la marche vous
dites quoi je trouve que c'est dommage
il a sûrement des bonnes raisons mais je
pense que ça aurait donné beaucoup de
légitimité et beaucoup plus de poids en
fait je pense que quand on est président
de la République on n'est pas jugé à ce
qu'on dit on est jugé à ce qu'on fait et
je pense que la présence du chef de
l'État aurait légitimer encore plus
l'unité nationale qui est nécessaire
aujourd'hui face à la lutte contre
l'antisé maintenant chef de l'État ça s
fait dans l'histoire vous souvenez quand
les attentats de 2015 franç s rendu
maintenant je vous dis voilà je
polémique pas il avait sans doute de
bonnes raisons de le
faire moi je pense que le Président de
la République aurait pu être dans les
rues et je pense qu'il a raté un
rendez-vous avec l'histoire parce que la
politique c'est une affaire de c'est
aussi une affaire de symbole et et je
crois maintenant que de cette marche
doit déboucher un sursaut politique
sécuritaire juridique pour protéger les
Français de cette nouvelle barbarie qui
se développe dans le pays et contre
laquelle nous alertons depuis 15 ans ça
fait 20 ans qu'on dit qu'il y a des
territoires aujourd'hui qui sont des
territoires perdus pour la République
qui sont désormais conquis par
l'islamisme et je trouve qu'on est
beaucoup plus faible à l'égard de
l'islamisme que ne le sont certains pays
musulmans eux-mêmes